welcome to this 15-minute game against
great Jean Grey Joan from Spain no name
please play mostly five minute and 15
minute with a pretty decent 15 million
drayton getting this is this all-time
high rating let's see what happens yeah
he really should play the room being
from Spain but you never know haha
scotch game or any I gambled yeah Bishop
c4 or something else okay I keep playing
this this funky check here but my
results are really good so I see no
reason to to deviate
normally c3m and then Bishop c5 the
argument that black has or wants to
prove is that this check provoking c3 is
really not helping white that much as he
very often would like to develop the
Knight to c3 yeah and here Bishop e3 is
normal there is also night be three or
night see two but this is the most
common continuation yeah here for a long
time it was thought that Queen g4s the
move but nowadays it it has become
apparent that both Knight f6 the gambit
continuation and Queen f6 our came my
problem is that Knight f6 I have never
looked at so if you place Queen g4 I
will ply Queen f6 I know that this is
reliable line so I don't mind playing
that night of six is really the more
attractive move but I'm not sure I want
to try to find all that now over the
bond
Queen g for Queen f6 there's very often
Queen g6 happening quickly afterwards so
that black clears the f6 square for the
night to develop so we near six is not
bad in terms of development so let's not
spend any big time here at least I'm
ahead on the clock lady
yeah yeah I think Queen g6 so I know
they're there was there was a game spar
off against 10 at once the cat took on
deform and this is a really risky but I
think you can do that him i'm not
mistaken this had been played by this
has been played by some strong GMS for
example i think by gabrielle soggy see
on the long-term second of Levon Aronian
and the wrong yet himself has played
vision before check so it's not it's not
a line that is totally a of beat black
also tax reform I mean not sure I can
take it but it looks like it looks
decent I think all this young okay just
Knight f6 I really i think 9 f 6m i
would really prefer him to take on g6 I
don't I can take on g3 it's not terribly
bad but I would prefer to for him to
take on on on g6 so let's keep the
tension for a moment okay so he tries to
directly use this yeah interesting maybe
this wasn't very precise to this c7
Assessor a problem okay I can take
though and play Queen to a king to d8
maybe just yeah that's not promote not
bad actually
King d8 is not bad it keeps this
protected and the king is not so bad on
d 8 it also clears the way for looky aid
and here i think white white will
probably take on be sick so he they are
probably you all
yeah we don't don't see a big
alternative to that 94 Beckham and turn
yeah okay he went back um yeah just
rupee eight probably provoking f3 looks
very a very normal maybe 90 for the salt
so what's interesting ok this is the
keep it simple approach really yeah if
he even takes on b6 now I have a very
comfortable position this is this type
of paw information with those this is
this kind of porn pack here that's very
nice for black it's very flexible can go
be 5d 55 and I have a no half open a
file very useful the Sun I didn't expect
at all maybe yeah okay he wants to he
just the techs h7 here this way
ya can do that it's a very simple but
maybe not bad
yeah I have one problem is i would like
to play d 5 but there is always long
castles opening quickly
really we had play here by white I mean
but it seems to be okay quite surprising
i just find it we had night b5 back
again then taking and for some reason
why it still should be good fine we had
very weird yeah but maybe my king
position on the eighth is not ideal
that's that's clear
yeah I probably have some ways to to be
okay here but not not really convinced
what to do I mean he takes on f6 and
takes IH subnets quite quite something
yeah I really don't see anything else I
need to get this counter plane if we
castles long I can also take F to where
the sisters is important one from okay
yes I just see can take h 7 immediately
yeah now I don't really have a decent
mood on route after Luke g7 no that's
immediately a threat on f6
I don't really I don't really see a
movie m47 is very very problematic
maybe rook e8 was just a bad move I mean
before that I must be okay no doubt look
maybe rupee eight was really a mistake
you choose we at Bishop g5 rook g80 just
takes I mean hook g7
yeah I don't even see a playable move I
mean not not not that I'm not seeing a
good move I don't see any move King d 7
may be lacking one it's probably not
mentoring anyway looks like I'm toast
here at least being a pawn down without
any compensation Butchie 794
yeah maybe yeah maybe this is even
playable if I look now that I think of
it rook takes rook takes Bishop e2 s
Bishop a 6 well maybe maybe this is not
so terrible check
they're funny is if you move the King I
cannot take F 2 because I would have
seven just funny
it can just play kinky too and as much
better intending Bishop d3 i have worn
down and i don't have any way to protect
up seven now i have very stupid moves
king-8 king e6 and to be honest what i
find highly suspect us that he's
thinking here while King d2 is totally
obvious it's a fairly new profile
they are hard to read anything into this
but how do you spend that Thun a minute
on kingda to which is totally forced
King the oneness is ridiculous really
this should be to Bishop a six is very
easy yeah okay yeah yeah promise I don't
have a move here kini six this Bishop e6
Bishop d3 mummy King six this Bishop b3
I have no way to cover him
yeah I don't see a move I really don't
yeah Bishop d3 is coming anyway to get
get some some development going here
kini 8 is just running into his check
I remarkably bad position really
hmm maybe I move the rook back what is
what is it doing really
I'd seen a move I mean I have seven is
falling maybe can maybe give give up the
exchange try to hold on like that takes
takes king of six I don't know it's it's
a loss in any case and I rook g8 now for
example is quite strong making sure that
I cannot even activate the a drug but f2
is hanging up maybe he wants to cover
cover f2 first check
and pawn a pawn and in exchange that's
quite quite a lot ff5 King f6 maybe
not sure that f4 was the best
technically but okay it's a win in more
than one way certainly
and always starting to play some strange
moves but ok I can go here and then he
wants to do this
yeah I can for instance King f6 rook
edge flow i can take play Bishop left
when win the porn but I don't want to
exchange looks here of course may be
still and then let's say would be aid
trying to get Bishop F to keep keep
Bishop f2 in the game and and maybe try
to do something against the B porn
I find this time time spent here really
strange it's at two times ok yeah but I
don't think it's a computer he played
some really strange moves don't think
this is computer issue just feels a bit
strange at some types what's happening I
mean you had prepared to look age four
and now he is rethinking if he wants to
play work g5 or what exactly is the
point it seems that way
so Bishop f2 is playing rook b1 yeah
okay maybe this first
which is somewhat weird root position at
least can get get in some active news
bill Bishop f2e edges rupee one and I'm
trying to get an improved version of
that
check
yeah Bishop f5 is also winning here we
unfortunately
maybe a default be sure between just
trying a bit but it's got King see to
wear this is fairly easy
check
yeah yeah for always tricky well what
should you try to to er-2 to complicate
matters in the lost position I'm trying
with c5 and d4 but the f5s just winning
so in a check major with root g 7i can
also resign but I don't like it check
keep 43 yeah it sounds really a weird
game I really think it was a weird game
with them Bishop g5 suddenly being a
decisive that was really strange yeah I
can play book a six rupee five and just
get into a winning king and porn and
game the problem
amongst other sign his channel has got
more than one way to win check ya know
f6 simply
you have no counter play yeah my resins
very typical game for being out of shape
in some way I don't really think this is
any good for white but rookie eight yeah
maybe this is really a mistake as weird
as it sounds
this is just wrong I mean this is just
wrong I think it's very weird very tired
way to play but it's just concretely
working winning winning the h-bomb and
busted here as simple as that just
walking by by concrete means check check
yeah I find it weird that he spends a
minute on kingda to what exactly as
there is no other move simply but okay
check yeah I don't know look you that's
probably all winning that's that's the
real problem yeah yeah there was nothing
really a check is just struggling on but
there is no no real chan way to save the
game it's really remarkable rupee aight
i think i prayed it relatively quickly
yeah it looks like a totally normal move
check but Bishop g5 is just so you
cannot it's beyond saving I must play
these six first year that's just a
fairly normal position I don't think of
something tell if that terribly bad is
happening to me here maybe maybe 90 f6
is some something where you can improve
but ok it's not necessary this is a this
is okay really
now just t6 what can you do okay thanks
for watching